King the dog is enjoying a steak
well-done at Sardis the famous theater
district restaurant in New York he
deserves it because he just won Best in
Show at the 140 third Westminster Kennel
Club dog show in 2019 then he tried to
eat a microphone King is at the end of a
long list of terriers to win Best in
Show at Westminster but King as
wonderful as he is will almost certainly
not do what this dog did this is the
only dog to win Best in Show at
Westminster three times in a row
that's a three-peat how did she do it
and was she really the greatest dog of
all time the answer involves a breed a
socialite in the short life of a legend
named Warren remedy
[Music]
this is not a steak this is a rat
terriers made their reputations as rat
catchers first bred in the British Isles
the Smooth Fox Terrier and Wire Fox
Terrier crossed over to America Warren
remedy was a Smooth Fox Terrier while
King is a Wire Fox Terrier the dogs
don't just share a Best in Show title
but also a common Fox Terrier heritage
with just a few exceptions the American
Smooth Fox Terrier started off in the
1880s in the oldest of our great kennels
Warren kennels the one started by
Winthrop Rutherford Rutherford was a
wealthy Manhattan socialite he dated a
Vanderbilt before marrying a vice
president's daughter he was also really
into terriers Rutherford was president
of the American Fox Terrier Club funding
it and working to boost the breeds clout
he also raised them at his estate in Ala
Moochie New Jersey hi what county are
you in so that's why his kennels were
called Warren kennels so that is where
Warren remedy got her name Aldi Warren
kennel dogs were Warren something and
all that stuff sets the stage for the
confluence of events that would make her
not just a dog but an icon
[Music]
let's go back to King King didn't just
win for being the best dog he won
according to standards used by
Westminster Kennel Club dog show judges
standards of what night deal Wire Fox
Terrier is he has small v-shaped ears of
moderate thickness a flat top line of
the skull a coat with dense wiry texture
the terrace of downs and condition it's
not just an awesome dog but the dog that
best exemplifies the breed Winthrop
Rutherford helped write the standards
for the Smooth Fox Terrier for his club
and Westminster the Westminster Kennel
Club started shows in 1877 just a few
years before Rutherford's warren kennels
started it didn't have Best in Show a
competition between breeds until 1907 by
then Rutherford was a member of the
Westminster Bench show committee and
guaranteed prize money for the smooth
and Wire Fox Terrier categories he
reigned one of the two top Smooth Fox
Terrier kennels in the country other
dogs were measured by the type he'd
established his dog Warren remedy one
shows around the country the judges
called her the sprightly clean-limbed
little mints and raved that she was
truest to type but is it any wonder that
she won Westminster specifically again
and again and again the surprise isn't
that she won three times it's that she
lost a fourth time to the other big Fox
Terrier breeder out of Texas sabine
kennels
even though sabine beat warren remedy it
wasn't really a loss for their brother
for time a dog from the sabine kennel
siren warned remedy he was her dad
so what do we do with Warren remedy was
she really the greatest dog of all time
after the reign of the Smooth Fox
Terrier wire Fox Terriers became cooler
all the way up to King in 2019 a Smooth
Fox Terrier never won after 1910
regulations also got stricter in 1924
there have been a couple of repeat
winners since but no three timers and no
two timers since 1972
that's over before that even an elite
dog like Warren remedy had a window
[Music]
a 20-year Smooth Fox Terrier trend a
short seven year life in three years as
best-in-show in 1906 she needed a little
size yet but had time by 1909 even when
she was queen of all dogs at westminster
sabine kennel dogs were winning other
competitions across the country but for
a couple of years she had the glory she
endorsed sprats dog cakes she earned all
those front page headlines
maybe those three wins maybe they were
about socialites and structure and
trends maybe she wasn't the greatest dog
of all time but the window is small for
every dog maybe they're all the greatest
for a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe all the dogs deserve one night
when they get the steak
[Music]
Oh
so maybe you're curious when the terrier
reignover best-in-show finally ended and
it didn't happen until 1913 when a
bulldog this big boy named strat a
Prince Albert managed to pull off the
victory
[Music]